SPEAKER: It's officially week
three of the Google Cloud Next
OnAir, which means we're
focusing on infrastructure.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we're taking a sneak
peek at this week's content.
Week three is all
about infrastructure,
meaning we want to help
you migrate and modernize,
so we've got tons of
informational sessions
from virtual machines
to networking
and looking at the details
of cloud environment.
This week is also full of
customer migration stories,
so you can hear the decisions
that drove companies
to the cloud and how they
planned out their migration
strategy.
Let's shine the spotlight on
Proactive Network Operations,
a session that shows off how the
Network Intelligence Center can
help you monitor, troubleshoot,
and even visualize
your network.
This session is pretty
cool because whether you're
about to migrate to cloud or
you've been there for years,
network outages are
always concerning,
so learning to be proactive
with your network operations
is a skill that will
always be valuable.
Fun fact.
I'm kind of a cloud nerd, which
is why my playlist has Alerting
Best Practices.
This session will be
a thorough explanation
of the alerts feature
in Google Cloud
Monitoring and the many ways
you can tweak your alerts
to find meaningful
signals in your data.
From aggregation to
filtering and grouping
and even to aligners,
there's plenty to learn,
and I can't wait.
To wrap things up, check
out the weekly recap
with Brian Dorsey, who will
also be hosting a Q&A session.
It's a great chance to
hear some of the answers
to questions like which
cloud offering you should use
in which scenario and what you
should think about when looking
at an enterprise migration.
With all of the
sessions this week,
you can feel ready to manage
your cloud environment.
To add these sessions to
your digital playlist,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment below or
tweet us using the hashtag
#googlecloudnext.
We'll see you in the cloud.